i want to announce bobo's ultimate
question
what's that bobo uh as you know is
always accused of asking um
bad questions when he calls in
they're really hardly questions they're
almost not questions at all you're right
and it's ironic because he probably puts
more work into his questions than any
other caller does he puts tremendous
hours in
yes
in fact we had uh marianne from brooklyn
coach bobo to improve his questions what
i want to ask is howard had mentioned on
the air about a documentary with scott
shannon he even asked robin hey did you
watch wait wait wait do we have a phone
click
get to the [ __ ] question oh no i'm
telling the backdrop of how i i was
gonna want to hear that don't you know
what it takes to be a good caller get to
the point unbelievable we decided bobo
needs a mentor this summer this is what
we came up with so bobo's going to have
a mentor this summer someone with
experience asking interesting questions
oh no we asked bobo who would he select
to mentor him and here was his answer
sly stone is incredible with his wisdom
i follow him on his instagram he's
always putting up this and at the end
and he's helped me with this marianne
thing because his days i i i've
struggled and i hear his last words keep
punching and when i go to the gym i hit
that bag i'm thinking that same thing i
put all my aggression in that bag and
i'm hearing rocky's you know stallone's
that words keep punching next on bobo's
list was sarah silverman the comedian he
uh he if he
if he can't get sylvester stallone
definitely
i like her podcast and tune in every now
and then she's very articulate she's
very smart maybe funny i could see her
sitting down and uh
going over some of my questions
while i'm standing at that boobage sorry
um
staring at your
boobage and your clittage my [ __ ] is
rock walk hard
sour
your thoughts sour sour what do you
think of sour
shoes bobo's third choice for mentor for
the bobo's ultimate question
was believe it or not our own fred
norris oh
and his his fantasy is that he's going
to invite himself over to fred's house
for the weekend listen
this
i love to work to
fred i would love to spend the weekend
at your place and uh you can help me
craft my questions and you can have the
bobo puppet there i can have a whole
interaction and uh hang out by the way
the ocean the water i always get
inspired by the ocean taking walks in
the beach and throwing rocks in the
water watching the rippling effects and
hearing tons of the waves and like
hanging out i like that yeah fred's
going to sit there and do a show for him
he's going to have the booboo puppet on
his lap and just be doing bobo for bobo
you could put the fist you put up the
bobo puppet up my ass
i hope i hope when i'm walking on the
ocean with fred he doesn't throw me in
the ocean and drown me
or take the walks that we flow in the
ocean and throw them on my head bobo's
fantasy weekend with fred continued
here's uh here's the fantasy a little
more fleshed out i just picture the sun
coming up he's singing this to me here
comes the sun down by the ocean that is
coming up
and here comes the sun like what if this
is a new day bubble uh it doesn't sound
like there's gonna be a lot of time to
go over bobo's questions for the olympia
bobo's being entertained the entire time
fred's working like a dog to make sure
bobo's happy anyway bobo's ultimate
question so we're going to get bobo a
mentor he's going to come back from the
summer with a question that's so good in
fact that he's interested in working
with the following people
uh as we said sarah silverman and
sylvester stallone and fred but also
jennifer aniston conan o'brien jimmy
kimmel jimmy fallon and michael
rappaport so there you go all of those
people signing up for it
who knows we'll see what happens for
bobo's ultimate question